the Joe Rogan experience the Marches
after Boris Johnson's election weren't
about fun they were that was an
explosion of rage
I didn't see that it is weird to me that
he looks like Trump that's like your
version of Trump I think he's he's not
the same it's not the same please just
name rocky here and yeah and he's got
that reputation of saying what he thinks
and all the rest of it so there's
similarities but I don't think they're
comparable Boris I don't support Boris
but he's very smart and he's very yeah
he's a smart guy and he's um you know
I've never voted for that his party
we're ignorant to your country over here
yeah I was at a platform while so he's
in the Conservative Party we only pay
attention to the Queen and the king
really the prince and whatever prince is
in trouble because he was banging chicks
on [ __ ] Ireland Oh Prince Andrew France
who's leaving but you pay that your
interest in the family that they have no
power okay and you know I mean you you
stole Harry from us then yes you got him
back and you turned him woke you turned
him really working then just as you walk
oh my god yeah yes oh so Megan market is
completely she turned him into a wok
stir 100% and bare mind he used to be
the one who used to go sort of parties
and do drugs and what if he did drugs
actually I should call her father she
made him walk um yeah he's a super woke
now hmm well it's gonna move to Canada
it's a good place to be woke that's why
but they're also saying that he can't
move to Canada because if you're a royal
from England I'm supposed to have a
primary residence in Canada because they
thought the Commonwealth or something
yes ideas like you can't come in there
and take over because if you did he's
lost his title now why you grandma that
says a lot she was pissed off oh she
just said no you can't of your title
you've got to pay for your cottage all
that money you took from the taxpayers
you gotta pay for not a cottage by the
weight of bigger states but they call it
Frogmore cottage but it's funny to me
that you guys are here more interested
in in some sort of outmoded anarchic an
archaic institution yeah like the royal
family and not so there isn't really an
awareness of our political situation we
know brexit bad brexit bad but bricks
it's not bad that's all we hear you hit
brick cracks it bad and but why racist
right okay so bad but that can I
say this because I know brexit probably
bores people but the problem with the
whole brexit thing is people thought it
was about rate at race people thought it
was like you voted for the EU if you
were a good person and voted against if
you're a bad person correct it wasn't
that no no Who am I - you've been lied
to it was a most people voted because
they wanted the idea in fact the polls
straight after the vote said that the
number one reason why people voted
brexit is they wanted the laws to govern
their country to be made within their
country which strikes me as a very
reasonable proposition right if you if
you're a Democrat you want to be able to
vote out the people in power you can't
vote out those bureaucrats and Brussels
you can't do it that's the principle
it's not because we want to go back to
some pre-war nostalgic or white country
this is a complete lie and it's just
experientially unsound I mean I don't
meet anyone like that you know but
that's the way it's been spun you know
what and also by the way if your
left-wing and you're supporting the EU
which is this neoliberal trading bloc
that is really pro corporate ruthlessly
so then I don't know how you can even
call yourself left-wing to be honest so
what is the anger in the streets in
England it's because of the miss goes
back to what we were saying about the
press so we had six months of debate on
the brexit issue before people voted so
people really knew what they were voting
for they knew what these issues were
about but the media was constantly
spinning and saying if you vote leave
you're a racist and if you vote to
remain in the EU you're one of the good
guys that was the narrative they were
spinning from the start and people would
and you know what it did it did that
thing of generating resentment did
anybody step out that that's logical and
objective to say hey yeah you can you
can look at this at a different way but
those voices got drowned out by the
utter swill that was being spilt out all
the time right and I'm not denying that
there were some racists in the UK and
that there are some of them might have
voted Li there were probably some races
who remain whatever but there's such a
minority and when you've got a media
class constantly saying to you you're
you all you poor working-class people
you're scum you're racist you hate you
know whatever then they're gonna go in
that voting booth and they're gonna
they're gonna say [ __ ] you and they're
gonna vote out and that's what happened
and it was a big backlash against being
patronized people hated it you know and
it's that I you know I hate that
narrative that
we live in a racist country when be
absent and that BRICS is used as
evidence but I see it as comparable I
think it's very different to the Trump
election but I see the one thing that I
think is comparable is that the premise
right if you got all these sort of woke
activists who say that they believe that
we live in this fascist country and that
they believe a fascist would vote for
Trump and then when Trump wins they use
that as evidence for the premise that
they set up right and that's why they
double down because they say well he won
so therefore we were right all along
with we're a country full of fascists
like yeah but your premise wasn't right
so so that and that's how you that's how
we need to break that sit that's that
sort of cycle of doubling down on the
the same [ __ ] and and and
guaranteeing Trump another term by doing
so by the way
[Applause]